One important feature of inverse functions that we haven't really talked about,
is the fact that they are, well, functions. Here for example, are the functions
we were working with in the last quiz. We started out with the equation y
equals 4x, and found that its inverse is y equals x over 4. Of course, the
original equation is a function, but we can tell that its inverse is too. It
passes the vertical line test. We saw that y equals 4 over x is its own
inverse. It passes the vertical line test, too. Another fun fact about this, is
you can tell that it's its own inverse, because the function itself is
symmetric across the line y equals x. Now if we had a function and we went
through the process of finding its inverse, but the resulting equation did not
graph a function, then the original function would not have an inverse at all.
I know that sounds kind of complicated and that would involve a lot of steps.
So luckily, there's an easier way to tell whether or not a function will have
an inverse. It involves graphing. Now I just said that we can figure out if a
graph represents a function by using the vertical line test. And we also know
that in order to graph the inverse of a function, we need to reflect it in the
line y equals x. So, what if we decided to reflect a vertical line in the line
y equals x? Here, I've graphed a random vertical line. I happen to pick x
equals 4. And this dotted black line is the line y equals x. What is the
reflection of x equals 4 in the line y equals x? Please write the equation of
this new line in this box.